[موسيقى]
والشمس
وضحاها والقمر اذا
تلاها
والنهار اذا جلاها
[موسيقى]
والدي كان امام مسجد رحمه الله عليه
وامام معروف في منطقتنا
نحن من وسط الصين ولايه خنان
مقاطعه خنا
فيها اكثر من 110 مليون نسمه
وكذلك والدتي رحمه الله عليها هي امامه
للمسجد للنساء
[موسيقى]
لما كنا صغار حقيقه نحن تعلمنا حروف
او نسموها النطق اللغه العربيه
ولكن ليس نطق السليمه يعني باللهجه
الصينيه تعلمنا اللغه العربيه
الف وباء جيم حتى العرب يسمحوا ممكن لا
يفهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وا
وتسعين
فجاءني فرصه
ذهبت الى السودان كنت درست في السودان
جامعه افريقيا العلمي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في اثناء العمره
لا ادري جاءني يعني
عزيمه وهمه
ولا خلاص انا لازم يعني ارجع
وان شاء الله يعني
اريد اتبع ما وصاني الوارد